PERCENTAGE.
TWICE IN HIS LAST GAMES HE HAS
HAD 30+ SAVES.
LET'S GO TO OUR A GOOD NUMBER.
KNOCKED IT AWAY.
>> Ed: JONATHAN HUBERDEAU.
ARE YOU KIDDING ME? HAVE NOT SE
IN A WHILE.
>> Steve: YEAH.
AND HE HAS BEEN KILLING
PENALTIES RIGHT FROM THE GET GO
NOT ABLE TO CLEAR THE ZONE.
THE SHOT, AN
KNOCKS IT AWAY.
AGAIN, THE PANTHERS TAKE
POSSESSION.THINK IT
IS GOING TO GO BACK BEHIND THE
NET THE PATIENT'S OF
>> Steve:
>> Steve: IT WAS SLIGHTLY
KNOCKED OFF.
I THINK SOME  WHICH WAY IT IS G
TO GO.T IT OUT.
HE IS BEING CHASED.
FLIPS IT TO THE CORNER.
BENNETT AGAIN.
OVER THE LINE.
LAYS IT BACK FOR ANTHONY
DUCLAIR. R THE
PANTHERS.
YOU SEE HOW DES.
>> Steve: HE CATCHES UP SURE T
GAME.
IF HE
AHEAD.
ANTON LUNDELL GETS TIED UP INSI
THE BLUE LINE.